[Müzik]
hoş geldiniz
özellikle İzmir'de gastronomiden
bahsetmek konuşmak daha da keyifli bu
kadar güzel gastronomik olarak zengin
bir şehirdi Evet gastronomide yeni
başlangıçlardan bahsedeceğim çok hızlı
gitmek zorundayım çünkü yaklaşık 10 bin
Hatta 12.000 yılı 18 dakikaya sığdırmaya
çalışacağım Peki önce şunu söyleyelim
lezzet algısı kişiseldir nasıl parmak
izimiz bize özgüyse lezzet algımızda
gene bize özgüdür Yani benim gibi
ukalalar Kalkıp bu böyle tadıyor bu iyi
bu kötü dediğinde inanmayın siz neyi
beğeniyorsanız o güzeldir Çünkü Her
birimizin ağız yapısı algısı kültürel
mirası birbirinden farklı
Onun için birincisi herkes kendinin
gurmesidir
kültürel ve kişisel bir şey bu
ikinci önemli unsur lezzet Aslında
bütününde biz böyle lezzetli güzel
keyifli Yok çok güzel tadıyor Falan
diyoruz ama aslında bu bir Bodyguard iyi
şeyi seviyoruz vücudumuz için iyi şeyi
tehlikeli şeyde reddediyoruz mesela
doğuştan biliyoruz ki eğer bir yiyecek
yağlı ve şekerli ise bizim için enerji
kaynağı buna lezzetli diyoruz Eğer
biterse Türk kahvesi gibi tonik gibi ya
da acıysa Buna da toksik öldürücü
diyoruz fakat bir numarayı öğrendik
arada eğer kontrollü miktarda biter ya
da kontrollü miktarda acıysa ona
tahammül edebiliyoruz Onun için aslında
lezzet dediğimiz şey bize besleyici
gelen bize enerji veren bizi yaşatan
unsurlar
Peki bu güzel bir sorudur hiç kendi
tükürüğünüzün tadını bilir misiniz
bazen hasta olduğunuzda böyle insanın
ağzı hiç ağzımın tadı yok falan değiliz
ya İnsan kendi tükürüğüne 24 saat maruz
kaldığı için kendi tükürüğünün tadını
bilmez
lezzetli de şöyle bir şey vardır bir
yiyeceği çok uzun süre tüketirseniz
artık haz almazsınız Bundan dolayı
Mesela kuru fasulyenin yanında turşu
veririz 3 kuşak 4 kaşık kuru fasulyeden
sonra kurulur fasulyenin tadı kalmaz bir
parça turşu yersiniz ağzınız değişir hop
kuru fasulye yeniden güzel tatmaya
başlar Onun için mesela japonlarda
sushi'nin yanında Zencefil turşusu
verirler
Fransızlar da etin yanında patates
kızartması verirler Onun için bir tadı
üst üste tatmak
bıktırıcıdır
Ağız değiştirmek çok önemlidir Yani bu
kişisel bir şey bir kültürel bir şey iki
bir de insanın adapte olduğu bir şey
Peki nasıl bir hayatımızda değişim
oluyor bakın hepimiz Doğduğumuzda süper
hassas bir ağızla doluyoruz yaklaşık
ağzımızda 10.000 tane tat reseptörü ile
doluyoruz
fakat zaman içinde bu reseptörlerden
kaybediyoruz nasıl Elimizin içi
nasırlanıyorsa Ağzımızın içi de
nasırlanıyor biz erkekler deriz ya
eşlerimize ah annemin yaptığı
Karnıyarığı yapamıyorsun
Aslında öyle değil anneyi ve malzemeyi
bugüne ışınlasak bizim ağzımız Biz 17-15
yaşındaki değil yani ağızda reseptör
kaybı var Bundan dolayı tat algımızda
zamanla dinamiktir 60 yaşından sonra
baya tat kaybı yaşarız kadınlar emzirme
ve hamilelik dönemlerinde çok hassas
olurlar tat algıları
yükselirler vesaire Biz erkekler devamlı
kaybederiz
aşağı doğru devamlı kaybederiz 60
yaşından sonra da tatlar Artık bizde
Biraz daha zor algılanır hale gelir
Bunlar bizim genel algı biçimimiz Onun
için bir yemeği lezzetli diye
tanımladığımız zaman bir içeceği
lezzetli diye tanımlanırsam birçok şeyi
beraber düşünmemiz lazım bir tat
Tatlı ekşi bitter tuzlu ve umumia
sulandırıcı beş temel tat iki Roma yani
kokular
odunsu çiçekçi meyvesi gibi üç doku
yiyecek kırılgan mı yağlı mı
Efendim
parçacıklı mı Kumlu mu 4 olduğumuz ortam
sıcak mı soğuk mu nemli mi
ses yüksek mi düşük mü sonrasında sosyal
ortam dostlarla mıyız iş Yemeğin de
miyiz Yoksa sıkıntılı bir grupta miyiz
ve en sonda kendi ruh halimiz
mutlu muyuz o gün hüzünümüz İşte
bunların hepsi beraberinde bize lezzet
algımızı veriyor Mesela bir yiyecekle
içeceği beğenmediniz tattınız hemen
yiyecek içeceğin tadına kabarık bulmayın
önce bir karşınızdakini değiştir yanlış
adamla yiyorsanız ağzınızın tadı kaçar
Hani zıkkım eder yemeği Onun için önce
bir karşınızdakini değiştir olmadı
ortamı değiştirin Ondan sonra yemeğe
kaba attım
geçelim işin tarihine
elma bakın elma
bizim yiyecek içecek dünyasında o kadar
çok üzerinde kontrol dışı hikaye
yaratılmış bir şey mesela
düşünürseniz en en en ilk
peygamberlerden değil mi
edrem en iyi Hristiyanlıkta var bizde
var ondan sonra musevilik de var Her
dinde var yasak elma yiyorlar ardından
Pamuk Prenses'i düşün
ün gene elma bugünün büyük ikonlarından
teknoloji ikonu gene elma Biz hep
hayatta kalmayı yiyecekle ve içecekle
eşleştireceğiz
Peki hikaye nerede başlamış bundan
10.000 yıl önce
bereketli hilal'de başlamış
Güneydoğu Anadolu'yu da kapsayan böyle
ee İran
Irak suriyel Lübnan ve Güneydoğu
Anadolu'yu kapsayan yani bölge bereketli
Hilal diye geçer İnsanoğlu ilk defa
burada yerleşik düzene geçti tarıma
başladı
ineği koyunu
ehlileştirdi buğdayı ilk buğday siyez
buğdayı aynı Korne buradan çıktı ve
bütün dünyaya yayıldı nohut mercimek İlk
defa burada tarıma başladı ve ilk büyük
değişim burada oldu Çünkü ilk defa
burada yemek yaptık ondan önce avcı
toplayıcıydık hayvan buluyorduk Efendim
kök topluyorduk meyve topluyorduk
yiyorduk göçüyorduk ilk defa burada
yerleşik düzene geçtik bu nedendendir ki
göbeklitepe'de aynı coğrafyada
buğdayın atası göbeklitepe'ye 30
kilometrede Karacadağ diye bir
Coğrafyadan çıktı ve ilk bira ilk ekmek
ilk yemek burada yapıldı Onun için ilk
büyük değişim ilk başlangıç Güneydoğu
Anadolu'da olmuştur dünya gastronomi
tarihinde
ardından çok önemli bir diğer unsur daha
var aynı coğrafyayı etkileyen
biliyorsunuz uzak doğu baharat zengin
bir yer bütün bu baharat Tamam İpek Yolu
diyoruz ama bir o kadar önemli olan da
Baharat Yolu işte bütün bu zenginlik
haritada da gördüğünüz gibi hem karadan
hem denizden
Güneydoğu Anadolu'ya geldi
dikkat ederseniz gene hemen bereketli
işlerin olduğu yere
Evet zengin bir coğrafyaydı Burası
imparatorluklar vardı birçok medeniyet
vardı ve bunlar parasını ödeyip bu
baharatları satın alabiliyorlardı bu
baharatları da yemeklerine eklediler
yemek zenginleşti
Peki bugün dünyada konuşuyoruz en iyi en
önemli iki mutfak üç mutfak sayacak
olsanız hangileridir Fransız Mutfağı
İtalyan mutfağı Hayır efendim dünyada
temel iki mutfak var biri uzak doğu
mutfağı
bütün bu baharatların kaynağı İkincisi
de hemen güneyimizde
Halep ve Şam Mutfağı bu iki mutfak
dünyada bütün dünya mutfağına şekil
vermiş mutfaklar
niye bakın Çin'de şu anda Çin'de sadece
8 farklı mutfak var Bizim Türkiye'de de
bakacak olursak değil mi bir Ege mutfağı
var Trakya mutfağı var İç Anadolu
mutfağı var Karadeniz mutfağı var Biz de
Çin'den çok
şey değiliz geride değiliz şimdi temelde
fark şu; Avrupa rezil bir durumdaydı
orta Çağa kadar Avrupalılar yemek yemeyi
falan bilmezlerdi niye
Hristiyanlıkta 7 temel günahtan biri
oburluk yemekten haz almak çok büyük bir
günaha Onun için avrupalılarda çok uzun
süre orta Çağ'a kadar yemek sadece
yaşamak için gelirdi Biz hele burada da
yemek için yaşarız
ama Avrupa yaşamak için yiyordu Onun
için yemek çok basit ve çok
lezzetsizdi mesela bakın Orta Çağda
Avrupa'daki masalara Bakın Şu aşağıdaki
resimde soyluları görüyorsunuz yemekte
bir süspans var mı bir baharat bir şey
var mı kuşu Şap diye koymuşlar Hatta
birçok Yemeği tabağa bile koymuyorlardı
Ekmeğin üzerine koyup yiyip ekmeği de
köpekleri atıyorlardı yani Yemek çok çok
sevimsiz de Avrupa'da
birkaç nedenden dolayı bir din iki
baharat bizde
yemeği lezzettirmek lezzetli hale
getirme kültürü bizde
mesela Onlar için iyi yemekle kötü yemek
ayrımı yemeğin tadı değil yemeğin
kaynağını neresi olduydu et ürünlerinde
yerden ne kadar yüksekte o kadar
kaliteli en güzel yemek kuş
sülündür Şudur budur güvercindir ne
kadar yerden yüksekte ise o kadar
kaliteli
en kötü et yere en yakın olan
gene geyik iyi bacakları uzun koyun
domuz kötü Çünkü yere yakın Halk Yesin
parasızlar yesin sebze meyvelerde ağaçta
yetişenler en makbulleri yerde kök
olarak yetişenler En kötüleri Onun için
Avrupa'daki tek lezzet unsuru sadece
yiyeceğin yerden ne kadar yüksek olduğu
idi
fakat şöyle bir şey oldu şimdi düşünün
İslam dünyası Pusulayı bulmuş sıfırı
bulmuş dümeni bulmuş yemekler lezzetli
batı dünyası Afedersiniz Kafa çalışmıyor
niye enerji yok çünkü şeker yok
şekerin kaynağı uzakdoğudur
endonezya'dır şeker kamışından şeker
yapılır ve İslam dünyası bütün bu şekeri
hakimken Avrupalıların şekere ulaşımları
yok o zaman şeker pancarı da yok Bir tek
bazı meyve var Onun için İslam
dünyasının kafası yüksek enerjiden
dolayı çok iyi çalışıyor
Hristiyan Dünyası orta çağ Çünkü az
enerji alıyorlar
bizim Beynimiz için günde bir kaşık
şeker lazım kafamızın çalışması için
işte hikaye şöyle değişiyor ne zaman ki
16 yüzyılda Kristof Kolomb Amerika'yı
keşfediyor Amerika kıtasına ilk defa
şeker kamışını karayiplere dikiyorlar ve
böylece Avrupa'ya şeker gelmeye başlıyor
çok miktarda şeker gelince Avrupalıların
da kafası çalışmaya başlıyor ve Rönesans
oluyor bir anda Avrupa işte şeker
girişini sağlayınca bütün mutfağa sanatı
edebiyatı her şey değişiyor Önemli bir
değişim noktasında gastronomide 16
yüzyıl şekerin Avrupa'ya geliş
Peki sorarım hep kavga ederiz
Yunanlılarla sütlaç baklava bizim
baklava Türk mü Yunan mı efendim çok
özür dilerim ama baklava Türk mülk değil
Arap
şerbeti tatlının hepsi Araptır Yunan Hiç
değil biz Hani şeyden kurtarıyoruz orada
Doğu coğrafyası falan sütlaç ise sütlü
tatlılar Türk tatlılarıdır muhallebi
sütlaç Kazandibi Türk tatlıları sütlü
tatlılardır şerbetli tatlı nefsi Araptır
şimdi bir unsur 16 yüzyıl gastronomi
tarihinde büyük değişim ne zaman ki
Amerika'yı keşfettik bakın Türk
mutfağında salçayı çok severiz değil mi
Türk mutfağına sembolü sanki 19 yüzyıla
kadar biz domatesi bilmiyorduk
Amerika'dan geldi
Amerikalılar da teamboardo
Kızılderililerin düşünmeyin Çünkü dana
da 16 Yüzyıldan sonra Avrupa'ya yani
Amerika'ya gitti
birçok unsur mesela Mısır gene
Amerika'dan buraya geldi patates
Amerika'dan buraya geldi
Urfa biberi diye bir şey yoktu ki
biberin kökeni Amerika ne zaman ki
Kristof Kolomb Amerika'yı keşfetti
birçok gıda batıdan doğuya ilk defa İpek
Yolunun tersine geldi ve birçok gıdada
doğudan batıya Amerika'ya gene aynı
dönemde gitti Onun için Amerika'da ilk
defa bizon dışında büyükbaş hayvan
yetiştiriciliği başladı
Evet 16 Yüzyıldan sonra Avrupa ikiye
bölündü Kuzey patates
Güney domates biz domatesçiyiz
domatesi öğrendik Mesela Ruslar Eğer ilk
patatesi tanıştıklarında korktular
şeytanın icadı dediler ama eğer o
patatesi olmasaydı Ruslar açlıktan
ölürdü keza irlanda'da 1700'lerdeki
1800'lerdeki büyük açlığı gene patates
önledi ama o sırada yanlış bir gübreyi
ezilen birkaç milyon İrlandalı patates
yüzünden öldü
ilk Avrupa'ya domates geldiğinde Bunlar
Kurşun tabaklarda domates yemişler
domatesin asidi kurşunu çözüp yendiği
zaman insanları zehirlemiş yıllarca
domates zehirli diye Avrupalılar domates
yememiş
bakın İtalyan pizzasının ilk çıkışı
1880 domatesli pizza
yani
italyanların o meşhur pizzasında kökeni
pita Bizim Pide
gene Aslında doğum
Evet
bu soru daha
biranın çıktığı yer gene Güneydoğu
Anadolu İnsanoğlu ilk pireyi
takılı ilk topladığı yerde ekmekten önce
yapmış altta sahada görüyorsunuz biranın
ilk çivi yasası hali millet kafayı
buldukça Tabii daha basit hale getirmiş
Aslında gördüğünüz bir güğüm içinde de
bir arpa var yukarıda da görüyor musunuz
arpayı Bunlar banka dekontları şu kadar
param var anlamında söylüyor
şarap da gene Güneydoğu Anadolu'dan
bütün batıya ulaşmış Onun için gene
Anadolu bizim birçok içeceğin kökeni
tuz ve zeytinyağı baktığınız zaman
Mısırlılar zeytin yetiştiriyorlarmış
antik Mısır
salamurayı da bildikleri için zeytini
salamura yapıp meyvesini yiyorlarmış
antik Yunanlılar da zeytini salamura
yapmayı bilmiyorlar ama zeytinyağı
yapmayı biliyorlar zeytini sıkıp
zeytinyağı yapıyorlarmış Mısırlılar
Yunanlılara zeytin satıp karşısında para
ile zeytinyağı olarak alıyorlarmış
Evet kahvenin de tarihi biliyorsunuz
gene bu coğrafyada başlamasa da kültürü
bu coğrafyada başladı ve bütün dünyaya
Osmanlı üzerinden yayıldı Hatta
Hristiyanlara Papa 8 klement şunu acaba
desek mi bu bir Müslüman şeytan içeceği
desek mi diye başvuran yardımcılarına
kahveyi tattım bu kadar güzel bir şey
insanlıktan mahrum edemeyiz diye deyip
kahvenin batı dünyasında yolunu açmış
çay deyince de çay demliyorsunuz Çin'den
çıkmış Hindistan'dan çıkmış
İngilizler bunu ticaretine başlamışlar
çinlileri Afyon'da kavga kandırıp
uyuşturmuşlar ve Afyon savaşları çıkmış
Amerikalılar da
İngilizlerin aldığı vergiye gıcık olup
ilk defa Amerika'nın bağımsızlığını
Boston çay partisi ile ilan etmek için
bütün çayları Boston limanında İngiliz
çaylarını denize dökmüşler bu nedenden
dolayı Amerikalılar kahve içer çay
içmezler yani milli bir duruştur Evet
biraz Hızlanayım
Evet biz peynir yer miyiz yeriz Çinliler
Japonlar yer mi yiyemez çünkü bütün
dünyaya peynir de Güneydoğu Anadolu'dan
yayıldı ilk insanlar bu kültürü
geliştirdiklerinde
Laktoz tolerans yani süte tahammülü
olanlar batıya olmayanlar doğuya
göçtüler
Son olarak şunu da söylemek istiyorum
restorasyon ne demek yeniden yapılanma
Fransa'da çıktı 1700'lerin sonunda
restorasyon vücudu yeniden yapılandır
Onun için Restoran dediğimiz şey vücudun
iyileştirildiği yerdir Evet sunumumda
havar ama sanıyorum sürem doldu Onun
için sizden af dileyerek sunumu
sonlandırıyorum Umarım keyif almışsındır
çok çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]